welcome back it's far too
I'm Nisha's army escape
and when we left off I was I'm just
getting um
I don't really know what to do I'm kind
of lost in here they're just like
nothing to do
oh oh oh man I forgot about him
cry I thought he'd left whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's not a song
oh maybe I should hide in the closet
I think we're good he doesn't think so
why am I wasting the breaking a liner
Oh
something here
yeah uh I got a key
Oh
when you leave already what he's doing
anyway
sounds pretty [ __ ] about
what the [ __ ] is he doing
no no no no no no no I did not see me
can you leave now please
why does he drape my closet stop
Oh God this mod is so [ __ ] buggy
why does he rave the coffin
Shai do she's run for it
nananana nananana nananana nananana
nanana Oh
oh he doesn't follow me
so while he's raping closet I'll making
price yeah
my goddaughter so
anyway let's go
I was short first yeah
he's so hot I wish I was
well I'm actually don't what happened
here
freakin gangbang
oh I remember you
okay open it I'm an email saying
frickin on fire today
carry something here
you're coming with me I walk slow when
I'm with him all right I would have
brought in my voice because he's so sexy
I am so jealous of your sexiness
frickin vagina face
Oh
anyway some puzzle maybe I don't know oh
here we go
doesn't do anything
come on
I think I hid my head
come on oh my god hey I get lost right
it doesn't [ __ ] work why do why would
it put it there doesn't
let's go in here then oh I need my key
this game has a lot oh jesus great stop
it
what oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man ah it's over right Wow [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] close
oh [ __ ]
ah ah mind never mind never mind let's
go here oh no problem penis penis uh uh
oh man I think I just whipped myself ah
I why didn't it out man oh let's go here
let's just be more careful this time not
rush things
doesn't even say where we're going I'm
sad face
damnit this is pretty nice actually
freaking red doors and [ __ ]
ah no no no no open open it won't open
it's oh man he was just strengthen that
ass that's fine
strut all you want as long as you don't
start in my face
we got nothing nothing no Santa Claus
nada
here Prezi this game wants you to lose
every [ __ ] thing oh come on
ah I forgot that come on thank you
sanity potion I could really [ __ ] use
one of those in real life night not
anyway please he's pretty big
see if there's something behind here yes
key I'm a frickin genius 360 actually
that just blew everything as fast as
possible and some wait what is that
whoa whoa nope nope nope nope nope nope
no no nope nope nope nope nope nope
I need a sanity potion didn't help but
all had this pounding hazard she okay
frickin hole in the door sweet we got
I'll making progress
another key no one showed up I am so
happy right now
is a happy face Oh
but I have keys everywhere right I've
been here
well maybe we use the key that
Kennedy's
it's just there to piss me off I guess
there's never anything in these freaking
drawers it's like way too many items
knowing just say
and they use the same puzzle twice like
BAM whatever I'm not complaining okay
here we go
No
there we go perfect no break stuff
that's why the [ __ ] no oh I'm breaking I
always used to get a strange feeling
here in this room that's because I used
to master it anyway what anyway I said
in that chair okay
oh we got stuff here crew pride cow mine
aqua regia seems familiar just saying I
can't break this gotta try harder huh
epic throw it try to throw into the
ground and it looks like alright how do
I do that right okay you you're going
down mr. C no problem it's gotta be
something in here
Oh apparently not
May Day
okay so I mix these right combination
it's work
doesn't work huh so what the sauce do i
do then
maybe now that door opens this game
makes so much sense
those in here right I don't remember our
crime
where did that monster go anyway
okay so now these stories open right
like an opening at least
ah come on you've got to be kidding me
Oh
I miss something
I'm a looot expert there's no way I
missed something nope
I guess we're heading back then are you
sure about this Felix yeah I'm sure this
coming
cap [ __ ] your game
ah I don't know where to go ayo ayo
maybe I can put poop right in the door
because that makes so much sense
a lot of you guys asked me what I would
do if I were like in real life
amnesia Castle hey maybe I can remove
this - no I can't
I think everyone says that they would
jump off the window or something like
that but then the shadow would get you
eventually so that wouldn't work either
but yeah I probably do that or maybe
just I don't know camp in the corner was
more likely now that I think about it
yeah probably camp in the corner wait
for someone to rescue me there's like
nothing to fight with hair like you use
this and throw in your face but that
work well in penumbra by the way oh here
we go
freaking high does that even do looks
like it I'm not gonna say what it looks
like but anyway
come on I bet it on something
I keep walking in front wrong direction
god damn it okay now now you will open
it doesn't know bad